the Joe Rogan experience take a look at
the the social media what's going on
with you know Twitter Facebook they you
the CEO of YouTube we'll start there
said on on CNN basically anyone who says
anything out of line with the World
Health Organization is available it's
against our community guidelines the
World Health Organization has
flip-flopped back and forth you know
like several times I believe they're
clearly spouting out Chinese propaganda
to protect particularly in January when
they were saying that according to China
there's no evidence he could be
transmitted from person to person and
did you know the AP reported at that
time China knew and withheld the
information for six days so the day that
the World Health Organization tweeted
out no evidence according to China of
human human transmission we now know
according to the AP that China did no
and purposefully withheld that what
you've got going on with China right now
I question whether or not we're getting
close to an act of war and I know that
might be a little exaggerated but
they've got you know this is the story
was published in BuzzFeed news trolls
working either for China or within China
trying to slow down the response in
other regions like Spain Italy Taiwan I
think I think that the buzz be most
specifically about Taiwan sowing
disinformation so it would slow their
response things like that why well I
think China wants Taiwan right well that
was they're a rogue provinces how they
consider it yeah well that's why they
instructed the World Health Organization
not even mention the name Taiwan you saw
that video videos crazy where the the
head of the World Health Organization is
being interviewed and in the interview
the woman asks him about Taiwan's
response and he says I think China has
done a great job right and then first he
ignores yes and then he hangs up but he
did say China and she said Taiwan and
specific and yeah I think that's when he
hung up on and then he came back said
well and she goes whoa let's get back to
questions well I think we've already
covered it China's done a great job like
he's clearly avoiding but why does he
think he can do that like what what what
does China have on them money is it fun
is it fun China funding them I mean you
saw when I'm with the NBA and like
desert you know people don't want to
give that cold hard cash they're making
a bold bet you know and I mean you know
lucidity is
is know so this is I was reading about
this the Atlantic wrote about this in
2015 are we headed for a war with China
and through CDs trap says that whenever
a growing power seeks to upset the
dominant power it results in war and out
of 12 out of 16 times of the past 500
years it has happened so people have
been predicting a us-china war for a
really long time because of this
historical precedent it's not absolute
but it looks like I'm not gonna prime
historical expert or anything like that
but it looks extremely probable to me
I've had a lot of people get mad at me
saying that I was fear-mongering by
bringing this up but the u.s. just sent
two warships into the South China Sea
which china considers their own
territory when you look at what China's
been doing in terms of misinformation
clearly lying about the numbers that you
know there
I can't member who did this I think may
have been Germany removing China's
numbers from the charts saying they're
not real so China has been misleading
the rest of the world withholding
information on how by the infection is
they sent a strike group an aircraft
carrier through the South China Sea near
Taiwan putting Japan on alert the us's
aircraft carrier Roosevelt was disabled
because of the corona virus they
evacuated 80% of the personnel the US
doesn't what they called an elephant
walk in Guam where they have all these
bombers then the u.s. pulls him out
because apparently China's got some kind
of weapon that can just blanket Guam and
wipe out our forces next thing I know we
sent a kind of weapon do they know if it
can do that
it's I'm not entirely sure I'm you know
I'm getting my information from just
reading peripheral stories I'm not a
military no guy only felt that but it
really does you know so the u.s. just
sent two warships into the South China
Sea and I think they're doing this
because one of the things I read from a
military website was that the strike
force is testing us resolve the last
time that China has done this where they
sent a strike force around Taiwan
actually tried to you know take it in
some fashion the u.s. send a couple
super carriers and everything calmed
down now our super carriers in the
region were disabled by kovat well
didn't China didn't they go into a group
exercise with Iran after we killed that
guy oh I don't know yeah there was a
group exercise with China and Iran in
the sea that they did something like
some sort of show of you
right after Trump had that guy's
assassinated do you see what happened
with those Iranian gunboats they were
swarming us the US naval vessels and
then Trump ordered them if they do it
again
sink him llama do you know that
Venezuela tried to commandeering a
civilian yacht a couple weeks ago
what Venezuelan naval ship crashed into
a German owned private cruise liner they
were trying to count as my understanding
of the story because I know a lot of
people are they're not gonna want to pry
that analysis out they were trying to
steal it so they claimed healin yeah
they so I think the official word from
Venezuela was they thought this was a
fake cruise ship with assassins for
Maduro or something so they ordered it
to come into their their waters because
they weren't Venezuela Venezuelan naval
ships are ramming it sank itself yeah I
heard about that yeah yeah and so then
sometime after Donald Trump deploys two
US naval vessels to near Venezuela
near Venezuelan waters which he says are
for drug-related operations I'm not
gonna like I know I'm a lot of people
gonna get heated saying you know you're
talking about yeah yeah all I know is
that's what was reported who knows what
that means or what it leads to but
needless to say with it you know look
Russia's withholding wheat exports
several European countries have have
closed their borders within the Schengen
area they're withhold their people
trying to hoard food and we just had a
full-page ad in The New York Times
Sunday edition I think was from Tyson
saying the food supply chain is breaking
and we're getting ready for a major
shortage of food you know they have a
killed two million chickens Wow because
they didn't have anybody to butcher them
here's here's here's my concern when you
have these nation-states shoring up
their borders even within the European
Union that was crazy to me when you see
Germany and France and Austria closing
their borders to each other then you get
these war ships making these movements
you get people desperate for food you
see Venezuela ramming into a cruise ship
I say that say it could be that we're
hyper focused on it because we're bored
we don't only pay attention to the stuff
we normally pay attention to celebrity
gossip and politics now that we're not
doing anything we're really focused on
what's happening in international
territory or perhaps it's that we're
getting desperate and we're scared as
the economy tanks well if it wasn't for
mutually assured destruction I would say
yeah we're probably moving into a place
of war but when you have two nuclear
superpowers like China and the US it's
like what you know what do they do
what do you
do your gonna one guy gonna launch a
missile the other guy's gonna launch a
missile like what are they gonna do yeah
are they gonna go into a full-scale war
and wipe out everyone on the planet cuz
that's what would happen I think so I do
the thing is who would be more willing
to wipe out a giant chunk of the
population would it be China or would it
be the United States I don't think it'd
be the United States I think it'd be
China and I think it really depends on
how strange they are for resources and
whether or not they're really going to
lose the the the the difficult look in
China when this broke out what we saw
videos of them barricading people in
their homes welding their doors shut
yeah the doctor whistleblower there's
one story of Iran a journalist was
calling out all these things disappears
for a month comes back a month later all
happy like governments great we love him
really yeah we know we know what they do
we've seen we've seen videos now this
could be propaganda you know cuz I'm in
America so of course I'm getting this
information maybe the u.s. is trying to
you know build us up but I think you
take a look at that kind of behavior the
willingness to do anything by any means
necessary and at what point do you get
one person is in charge saying I will
not be the captain of a ship that sinks
you know I look - well I don't want to
get super political in American history
but I view it as you've got a leader of
a country and as people are looking at
him he says this will be the year my
country ceases to exist if that presses
a button I will not be the Lee you know
I will not be the person with its stain
it's hard to know though because it
could be a leader saying I will not be
the person who destroys the world I
would rather go down in history as the
you know failure of my country I I think
you back somebody into a corner and you
get fight or flight
[Applause]